human rights are universal but they're
not being realized for the children
because the children are vulnerable it's
easy to sell them to marry them off to
sentence them to a life of labor adults
are not particularly responsible in all
situations and they abuse children every
way we can think of so for us to rise up
as a community and say the rights of the
child need to be protected they need to
be established it's it's past time that
we stand up and do this
people are selfish and children are
victims over and over again and this is
why I mean although almost every nation
signed on to ratify the rights of the
child in fact in practice this is not
being experienced by millions and
millions of children around the world
and it's really incumbent upon us as
adults to impress upon other adults the
need to respect children and their
rights and I think a lot of it has to do
is simply re teaching adults that you
know just because a child is is small
and vulnerable you can you can do
anything to that child but it also
requires something stronger and that
means every government and all but two
governments did sign on to it must stand
by each and every child and we know
that's not happening but we must open
our eyes a little wider open our hearts
and become more active in shepherding
the rights of the child right down to
the level where it actually influences
every family every adult and finally
every child